Before doing anything else,
we first need to capture the values in
the tableau with a collection
of boolean variables.
We'll start with this State column here.
We let Qi represent whether after
step i, the state is q sub k.
Similarly, for the Head Position,
we define H, i,
j, to represent whether the head
is over square j after step i.
That captures this column.
And lastly, for the Tape Contents,
we define s, i, j, k,
to represent whether after step i,
square j, contains the tape
symbol enumerated as k.
That captures all of these columns,
here.
Note that as we define these variables,
there are many truth assignments
that are simply nonsensical.
For instance every one of the q
variables could be assigned
a value of true.
But in a given configuration sequence,
the Turing machine can't be
in all states at all times.
Similarly we can't assign
them to all be false.
The machine has to be in some
state at each time step.
We have the same problems with
the head position variables, and
with the variables for
the squares on the tape.
All of this is okay.
For now, we just need a way to make
sure that any accepting configuration
sequence has a corresponding
truth assignment.
For any way of filling out the tableau,
the corresponding truth assignment is
uniquely defined by these meanings.
It's the job of the boolean formula
to rule out truth assignments
that don't correspond to
a valid accepting computation.